Tim Johnson, what's up, bro. Is it possible advisable to dial in great content for a site and then migrate that same content, except change out city name and NAP.
I've heard arguments that Google doesn't like duplicated content so I've heard arguments both ways as well. All I'm going to say is that I don't do it. I've never done duplicate content.
We have a really like my content writers, we have two content writers, of all places in West Africa where I'm moving.
These are Lebanese. These are both Lebanese girls and I say girls they're they're women. They are incredibly educated Lebanese women they both have their master's degrees.
And what happens is we assign them content we teach them how to write content we assign them content. And we first and foremost we check it for plagiarism, right, and I trust them but you just never know.
So we check it for plagiarism, and then we go through it and we make sure that you know it sounds readable. We don't want it to sound like a robot wrote it we want to sound readable and sometimes when you are, you know.
Anyway, that's our process so I don't do it, I don't even mess with it, I don't try to because in my head it's like, by the time I've, you know, taking the content and pulled out the cities and done this and done that.
Man, I've spent half the time it would have taken me just to write new content or paid somebody to write me new content.
And I'm risking duplicate content so I don't touch any of that that's just my personal experience. If anyone else wants to give their opinion that's had experience, I just don't mess with it.
100% organic content, 100% my own people, and I not only played check it for plagiarism but we read through it for punctuation we read through it for readability. We spend a lot of time on good content, because it matters, because I know I can't change the age of my domain.
I can't change the age of my domain baby. What I can do is I can go get backlinks, and I can write great content you know what else on that point Tim is think about it like this.
I'm willing to go and rewrite content for pen concrete sites and write it from scratch.
I'm most likely going to be the next guy, the next guy, he's just trying to get a paragraph up or a couple sentences up so he can have a website to put on his business card, or her business card.
Okay, I want to dominate the areas that I can control, because I can't control the age of the domain so especially if you go into an area, and your main competitor has a 20 year old domain, you better be bringing the heat on the content, and you better be looking
for backlinks and you better be dialing everything else in because it's going to be, you're going to have to make up for that age of domain with your other stuff. Okay.